cette vidéo est sponsorisée par pandac
craft des kits éducatifs pour enfants à
découvrir en fin de
[Musique]
vidéo Paul connais-tu le plus grand
désert au
monde l'Antarctique exactement 14000
milliers de kilom²r ça vous étonne
attendez d'apprendre ce que les frayman
vont faire Adam J je suis présentement
en train de faire tomber ma caméra je
suis présentement dans le carou
sud-africain qui est un désert
semi-aride les désert c'est caractérisé
par la sécheresse et je confirme que
j'ai jamais vécu une sécheresse pareil
j'ai besoin de me mettre des gouttes
dans tous les orifices parce que c'est
vraiment c'est critique un désert c'est
moins de 250 mm de précipitation par an
moins de 500 mm pour les zones
semi-arides comme le carou où je me
trouvais juste avant bref dans ces zones
il y a plus d'eau qui s'évapore que
d'eau qui tombe et les déserts c'est des
milieux extrêmes même pour les
températures c'est les endroits les plus
chauds pour les déserts chauds et les
plus froids pour les déserts froids et
c'est là qu'on enregistre des records
absolus de température vers le glaglac
comme vers le oulala mon string de Borat
et trempé de transpit je obl a très très
peu de nuages dans ses écosystèmes donc
sans cette couverture nuageuse la terre
absorbe davantage d'énergie solaire le
jour et en émet davantage vers l'espace
la nuit il y a pas d'entre deux les
nuages ne permettent ni de renvoyer une
partie des rayonnements solaires pour
qu'il y fasse bon le jour ni d'en
emprisonner une partie des infrarouges
la nuit pour éviter qu'on s'y pelle le
Jon et oui ça s le vécu et un autre truc
ici c'est qu'il y a aussi énormément de
vent là aujourd'hui ça va à peu près
donc j'ai bien choisi mon jour pour
tourner mais d'habitude c'est un peu
terrible donc tout ce que j'ai tourné
sur le terrain je pense que je vais sans
doute faire de la VO dessus parce que
sinon ça va ressembler à
ça j'ai trou le vent là c'est
beauoup le vent commence à se lever et
je suis ravi d'avoir oublié mes
bonnettes de micro on considère que 30 %
de toute la surface terrestre est haride
donc c'est quand même un petit peu
énorme ça ça va dépendre de la latitude
du terrain et des conditions
atmosphériques enfin de la circulation
atmosphérique là je me suis auto spoilé
mais si j'ai bien fait mon travail la
question qui vous tarode à présent à
part pourquoi Renault continue de se
produire sur scène et qui a bien pu
devenir le professeur c'est pourquoi les
déserts sont secs à vous durcir le pain
de M si vous mettez plus de 10 minutes à
manger votre sandwich et bien c'est à
cause des chevaux les latitudes des
chevaux c'est un peu comme la diagonal
du vide mais avec moins d'Er et plus de
désert et oui parce que les zones arides
ne sont pas localisées à la V comme je
te pousse elles sont généralement entre
30 et 35 degr de latitude de part et
d'autrre de l'équateur la faute à la
circulation atmosphérique qui forme des
cellules de convection à la surface du
globe de l'équateur au pôle cellule de
Adley de Férel et cellules polaires à
l'équateur l'air chaud et humide s'élève
fait son petit footing du matin urine
sur les tropiques sous forme de bonne
grosse lui et poursuit sa route en
direction d'épaule avec le genre de
sécheresse qui nécessiterait de
consulter un gynéco vers nos chevaux
suspensionnés cette air rencontre l'air
de la cellule de Ferel qui se dirige
vers l'équateur lui aussi sec comme un
pruneo et les deux décident de faire un
bout de chemin ensemble et plongent la
tête la première vers le sol et paf il
nous crée ses ceintures arides vers
30°gr Nord et Sud là doncù on retrouve
pas mal de nos déserts favoris c'est
quoi votre désert préféré moi c'est le
le diramisou et donc c'est aussi pour ça
que ces régions sont si venteuse la
faute aux chevaux mais tous les déserts
ne sont pas danses de laattitude
Cavalière comme par exemple l'un des
déserts les plus c'est au monde le
désert d'atakama au Chili c'est le petit
chouchou des astronomes pour une bonne
raison c'est qu'on y trouve des
observatoires à l'appel mais plutôt des
observatoires astronomiqu forcément on
voit bien les étoiles vu qu'il y a pas
de nuage ni de pollution lumineuse et
qu'on en altitude le carou c'était pas
atakama mais j'ai pu prendre quelques
photos sympatoches du ciel avec un
matériel pas du tout adapté par exemple
ça c'est prè au smartphone je vous
laisse imaginer ce que ça donnait en
vrai mais je m'égare bon mais alors
pourquoi il est sec à takama s'il est
pas au bonne latitude et pourquoi c'est
même le désert le plus sexe au monde
parce que les es lui font de l'ombre de
l'ombre plus viométrique pour faire
court les vents grimpent en altitude
quand quand il survoles les montagnes
l'air devient plus froid et peut donc
transporter moins d'eau c'est pas moi
qui décide he c'est la physique il se
déleste de ses pluies ou de ses neiges
sur les Andes et arrive tout sec sur
attaque à main et c'est d'autant plus
amplifié que la région justxte un
courant océanique froid et puis il y a
aussi les déserts polaires dont Zenda
nous parlait en tout début de vidéo avec
l'Antarctique encore une fois c'est la
faute à la circulation atmosphérique bon
maintenant qu'on sait pourquoi un désert
se forme là où il se forme on va pouvoir
attaquer la vraie question comment un
désert se forme c'est là que ça devient
intéressant ça on va parler de cailloux
j'aime bien les cailloux AE a Aï le
retour du vent j'ai lu qu'il y avait
moins d'érosion dans les dans les
déserts qu'ailleurs parce qu'en fait le
principal facteur érosif je sais pas si
c'est comme ça qu'on dit c'est l'eau et
du coup bah comme il y a moins d'eau
dans les déserts bah il y a moins
d'érosion après pour en avoir discuté
avec Julien dans tractosciences qui est
paléontologue ici qui connaît bien le
terrain il m'a dit que c'était pas
forcément le cas donc je vais vous
montrer un peu ce qu'il m'a
raconté il y a pas que le vent qui rode
les roches dans le désert il y a aussi
la température on l'a dit entre le jour
et la nuit les écarts peuvent dépasser
40°g ça fait que les roches se dilatent
se contractent se dilatent se
contractent se dilactent se contractent
je pas parler au bout d'un moment elle
n'en puisse plus un peu comme vous en ce
moment telle un sphincter accro au
Tabasco elle fissure puis éclate en
plein de petits morceaux c'est la
thermoclasti et c'est l'heure de freiner
sur le piment et c'est là que le vent
prend le relais il va transporter les
fragments de roche et selon leur taille
les faire rouler ou les faire sautiller
sur le sol on appelle ça la reptation et
la saltation je peux vous dire que quand
les particules vous saltationnent dans
la face vous les sentez bien passer les
particules de sable et et de poussière
peuvent être transporté comme ça sur de
grandes distances les français
métropolitains se rappelleront peut-être
de ce ciel apocalyptique coloré par le
sable du Sahara en 2022 il y a aussi la
poussière chinoise qui se retrouve
régulièrement à Hawaï 10000 km plus loin
plus hardcore les vraies tempêtes de
sable génèrent carrément des champs
électromagnétiques les particules dans
l'air cell qui reptationne et cell qui
saltat se collisionnent en diable et
deviennent électriquement chargé ça peut
causer des étincelles et des
interférences avec les
télécommunications quand même mais sans
aller jusqu'à invoquer des tempêtes de
sable et autres scénarios catastrophes
le simple transport des particules par
le vent c'est déjà rigolo en soi puisque
ces particules qui étent un produit de
l'érosion deviennent un agent de
l'érosion il la rend n'est-ce pas je
avais bien dit quand elles sont
transportées par le vent elles vont
rouler taper sur les surfaces alentours
et les abraser les abrasir abrasoir
elles vont polir les roches un peu à
l'image du papier de verre et à force
d'éroder les roches on peut aboutir à
des énorme étendu de fines particules
très reconnaissable au microscope
tellement elles ont été émoussées
particules dont le sable que vous voyez
ici même si seulement 20 % des déserts
sont des déserts de sable des Herges des
des Herges c'est moins fréquent que ce
qu'on imagine le reste du temps il
s'agit de R des déserts de cailloux
débarrassés de leur sable par le vent
voilà c'était le point mot fléché
certaines roches peuvent même se mettre
à arborer un genre de patine naturelle
qu'on appelle le vernis du désert un
phénomène qu'on peut voir ici sur des
roches martiennes ou ici dans l'UTA
vernis qui a été gratté il y a 2000 ans
par les Premières nations pour former ce
paléoitart un petit peu impressionnant
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'ici la
végétation s'est vraiment adaptée
justement à la sécheresse et au vent
donc on voit des plantes qui sont très
basses qu'on un por prostré qu'on des
toutes petites feuilles pour retenir
l'eau et qu'elle s'évapore pas trop
enfin c'est assez rigolo de voir tout ça
c'est un une garigue un peu pimpée quoi
il y a des Acassia qui ont des épines
comasses je pense que c'est pour se
protéger en fait de la pression de
prédation pression de broutage des
animaux parce qu'il y a masse d'animaux
ici notamment pas mal de vaches je sais
pas si on les voit derrière moi pas du
tout faites
[Musique]
semblant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
revenonsen au désert de sable un peu
parce qu'ils sont particulièrement
intéressants côté géologique ce sable
grâce au vent toujours peut se ranger en
jolie ride typiquement éloigné de
quelques centimètres les unes des autres
et perpendicula à la direction du vent
ça ne vous rappelle rien et oui c'est le
même genre de structure qui se forme à
la plage et qui peut fossiliser tel
quelle je ne résiste pas à l'envie de
vous montrer les magnifiques riple marks
qu'on a vu en Afrique du Sud parce que
vous savez que c'est une de mes figures
géologiques préférées et et on en a vu
plein et elles étaient vraiment très
très belles or donc quel que soit
l'agent de transport R ou o on aboutit
au même genre de structure car les mêmes
processus sont impliqués dans les deux
cas la seule différence ou l'une des
seules c'est que dans le cas des rides
formées par le vent les particules les
plus grosses s'accumulent en haut des
crêtes alors que les plus petites vont
au fond des creux où elles sont
protégées du vent quand les rides sont
formées par l'eau bah c'est l'inverse
fun fact vous avais dit qu'on allait
s'amuser aujourd'hui et puis s'il y a
assez de matière le sable peut carrément
s'assembler pour former des dunes voire
des systèmes dunaires les fameuses
Herges dont on parlait scientifiquque
qui avait décidément trop de temps libre
se sont même amusés à faire les
mathématiques des dunes un grain de
sable grimpe la dune avec un angle de 10
à 20°gr et il la redescend avec un angle
de 32°gr environ vous pourrez pas avoir
un angle plus aigu quand on atteint
32°gr paf c'est obligé de dégringoler et
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait que les
dunes sont pratiquement un truc vivant
elles avancent progressivement avec le
vent un grain de sable à la fois pas
besoin de désir exotique pour ça
d'ailleurs c'est aussi le cas de la dune
du Pilard sur la côte atlantique la dune
du Pila et du coup comme la dune suit la
direction du vent si les vents tournent
on peut avoir des belles structures
géologiques qui se mettent en place un
peu comme celle-ci je sais pas vous moi
je suis je suis resté en admiration
devant cette photo pendant une
demi-heure j'exagère même pas et j'étais
sobre et alors vous ne devinerez jamais
mais on trouve aussi des Nunes de sable
sous l'océan en fait les processus sont
tellement similaires qu'il y a une moto
qui passe dans la
rue en fait les processus sont tellement
similaires que les chercheurs
reproduisent des dunes en laboratoire
dans des aquariums en remplaçant le vent
par de l'eau ça leur permet de faire des
dunes miniatur de les faire évoluer en
plusieurs voir heur plutôt que
d'attendre dans la nature plusieurs
années et les dunes en laboratoire sont
en tout point comparables au dunes de
nos déserts voilà je trouve ça assez
rigolo que les les chercheurs fassent
des déserts miniatures sur leur
paillasse on n'arrête pas le progrès on
arrête le progrès et figurez-vous que
ces dunes peuvent aussi traverser les
âges comme les désert c'est un
environnement très particulier du point
de vue climatique notamment il y a des
structures géologiques qui sont propres
au désert qui se forment que ici comme
notamment les lus et donc ça ça n'a rien
à voir mais je voulais vous la montrer
parce qu'en fait il y a pas de ici mais
en fait je voulais faire un plan
reportage pour donner du rythme à la
vidéo vous
voyez alors là je faisais la maline à
dire qu'il y avait pas de l'US ici mais
la suite du voyage allait me réserver
une petite surprise dites
[Musique]
donc
pour voir les structures dont je parlais
il faut se décaler un peu donc là on a
fait 8h de route on est à mafoué et
alors derrière moi il y a ce que j'ai
appelé des leus alors des leus c'est
quoi en fait c'est des dunes de sable
qui ont fossilisé TelQuel et c'est un
peu beau et alors l'Afrique du Sud est
quand même extrêmement bien LTI pour ça
parce que c'est juste un un modèle dans
les cours de géologie bah c'est ça qu'on
montre je dis leus mais si monsieur F
était là il dirait l' parce que il a un
peu à cheval sur la prononciation du E
dans l'eau mais comme faire sememblant
de s'y connaître ça va 2 secondes je
vais plutôt demander à Julia c'est quoi
le los l l'os alors ce sont des des
sédiments qui sont déposés par le vent
donc là ce qu'on a derrière nous ici
cette énorme gré c'est la formation
Clarence qui date du début du Jurassique
qui a environ 180 millions d'années
c'est un dépôt qui qui s'est formé dans
un désert qui ressemblait au Sahara et
ce sont des dunes dans lesquelles les
dinosaures ont mis les pieds et
tellement à tel point qu'on trouve des
empreintes de dinosaures un peu partout
on voilà une juste
là là en plus ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est qu'on a pas seulement des
empreintes de dinosaures on a une on a
même une piste du coup puisqu'on a 1 2
TR empreintes donc pied droit pied
gauche et repied droit là-bas en dessous
de irine ouais qui ont été met par qui
ont été faites par un dinosaure qui
avait trois doigts au pied donc
probablement un carnivore ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant avec ces empreintes c'est
qu'il y a des équations qui permettre de
reconstituer la vitesse des dinosaures
grâce à ces empreintes on va savoir
comment l'animal se déplaçait quelle
était la longueur de ses pas et cetera
et en plus ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est que Ben ces empreintes nous
montrent comment l'animal vivait
contrairement à un squelette où on a
comment l'animal est mort ces empreintes
là elles ont été faites par un animal de
son vivant et ça ça nous montre
exactement la biologie de cet animal et
donc en Afrique du Sud on a vraiment
cette cette chance d'avoir les koissan
donc ce qu'on appelle les bushman en
français qui ont fait des des peintures
de ces empreintes milieu des années 1800
ils ont découvert ces fossiles et ils
les ont interprétés ils ont fait des
peintures rupestres de ces fossiles et
ils ont fait une reconstruction de ce
qu'ils pensaient être le le l'animal qui
avait fait ses empreintes et ces
reconstructions était très précise
ressemblait exactement à un dinosaure et
quand on les compare à celle que Richard
Owen a fait à la même époque qui était
un gros dinosaure ballour avec la queue
qui traînait en fait on se rend compte
que les bouchem avaient mieux interprété
ce à quoi ressemblait un dinosaure
que Richard Owen lui-même Richard Owen
qui est le créateur du mot dinosaure je
le rappelle donc c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est parce que Richard Owen s basé sur
les EAU alors que les Buchman eux se
sont basés sur les empreintes ils ont vu
déjà qu'il y avait pas d'empreinte de
main donc on est sur un animal qui
marchait uniquement sur ses pattes de
derrière alors que si on avait eu un
animal qui qui était quadrupède on
aurait eu à chaque fois empreinte de
mains empreinte de pied empreinte de
mains empreinte de pieds et cetera et
ils ont vu que la queue en fait qui
aurait dû qui si elle avait traîné
aurait dû laisser une marque ici
exactement comme ça le fait chez les
crocodiles or là il n'y a rien la queue
était soulevé du sol exactement comme
vous voyez dans le film Jurassic Park
alors là figurez-vous que on a trouvé un
fossile que je dis on c'est pas moi du
tout mais
olbeng une étudiante de Julien qui a
trouvé un fossile en
direct et dans celle-là on voit les elle
est là pointe vers le bas ah oui ah
ouais très très
beau là je me suis rapproché je sais pas
si vous voyez ça c'est une griffe ça
aussi et l'autre doit être par là mais
je la vois pas très bien et en passant
les empreintes qu'on vous a montré là
elles sont vraiment toutes nouvelles
enfin pas littéralement mais on vient de
les découvrir quoi par que l'experte en
empreinte de dinosaures du coin ne
connaî pas ces emprintes vraiment là on
est en train de parcourir le site de
découvrir plein de choses je sais pas si
vous voyez les découvreurs par
là-bas on s'amuse bien je voulais vous
remercier d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à me dire ce que vous en pensez dans
les commentaires et puis on se retrouve
bientôt pour d'autres vidéos sur le
carou je remercie Julien dansre
actoscience parce que c'est grâce à lui
qu'on est là et c'est grâce à vous grâce
à vos généreux dons c'est pour ça que je
suis là avec avec Pumba et Pumba et et
plein d'autres que vous allez voir très
bientôt j'espère pouvoir vous montrer un
peu l'envers du décor avec des for ma
cours et des format long sur la chaîne
dans les les semaines voire mois à venir
voilà donc j'espère que ça vous ira et
que ça apportera un peu de soleil dans
vos vies et ça Tom bien qu'on parle de
désert parce que vous savez ce qu'il y a
aussi dans le désert l'Égypte et c'est
justement le thème du kit pandac craft
de ce mois-ci dites donc pour ceux qui
ne les connaissent pas panda craft ce
sont des kits éducatifs pour vos
bambbins chaque mois par la poste votre
petite madeleine votre archibalde
receverra un colis comprenant un
magazine éducatif une activité manuelle
et son guide le tout sur un thème donné
qui change tous les en décembre on
célèbre la mythologie égyptienne en
janvier les volcans en février les
Romains joyeuse fête romain en plus il y
en a pour tous les âges un abonnement
pour les 3 5 ans un autre pour les 5 8
ans et un troisème pour les 8 12 ans
j'ai pu tester ces kits je peux vous
dire que je me suis diverstruite en
diable c'est une activité très rigolote
à faire avec son enfant ou ou son enfant
intérieur et c'est justement l'occasion
de découvrir les kits de ce mois-ci pour
les 3 à 5 ans un super magazine oh c'est
beau ça prépare Noël et l'activité un
chambou tout avec les dieux égyptiens ça
c'est toutes les consignes oh ça va
chambouler pour les 5 h ans nous avons
les dieux d'Égypte ils sont beaux les
magazines en plus à chaque fois et
l'activité la course des dieux fabrique
ton jeu de société et sois le premier à
emmener ton Dieu en haut du podium une
bonne activité du mercredi après-midi et
enfin pour les plus grands j'adore ce
magazine là parce qu'il y a toujours des
fun fact très rigolo et c'est hyper bien
écrit activité le défi des dieux
fabrique ton jeu sur les dieux égyptiens
et jou et en plus s'il y a un souci pour
le montage il y a des QR codes avec des
vidéos de démonstration ça c'est toutes
les carte pour jouer un D la boîte pour
ranger les cartes en plus c'est hyper
beau je sais pas si vous voyez la
qualité du du truc je connais des neveux
qui vont être un peu contents de
recevoir un cadeau de Noël qui n'en
finira plus puisque chaque mois il y en
aura un nouveau mais surtout leur dites
pas ce sera une surprise vous aussi
offrez à vos Peet un cadeau qui se vivra
toute l'année imaginez les étoiles dans
leurs yeux à l'idée de fabriquer des
machins et des bidules tout en apprenant
des trucs et grâce à ma générosité sans
born ellisabeth bénéficier d'une
réduction de 15 % sur votre abonnement
ou vos abonnement soyons fou une offre
exceptionnelle valable pendant un mois à
retrouver grâce au code promo Fiona et à
mon lien est en description merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci à
panda craft de l'avoir sponsorisé la
prochaine sur Afrique du Sud parlera
peut-être de cratèr de météorites je
sais pas dans le loout abondancev la
[Musique]
cloche